so in the haunted house
hopefully you'll feel like this is a
family and not just some fun Halloween
job
that is part of the trailer for the new
horror movie Teddy told me to the film
debuts this weekend at Sin City horror
Fest and The Man Behind the movie is
Boulder City's own Tom Devlin it's good
to see you buddy good to see you man
it's nice to have you in the studio
because we're always out at your monster
museum for Halloween so it's nice to
have you here in studio with us this is
great Teddy told me to I'm excited about
this we'll get you why I'm really
excited about in a second but what's the
movie about so what Teddy told me too is
about is there's a happy couple that
buys a rundown haunted attraction that's
been closed for years there's a little
bit of a urban legend behind it but they
ignore that by the haunted attraction
try to reopen it for the season and of
course all Mayhem ensues and that local
Legend comes back to terrorize and this
whole thing was filmed in Boulder City
kind of focusing on your monster Museum
right yeah the whole thing is filmed on
and around the monster Museum I have a
haunted house building there called the
fright zone and that's where the movie
takes place and the couple's Loosely
based on me and my wife okay all right
uh that's it they taught his wife like
that she loved it yeah she loves it and
uh you know because it's just not so far
from the truth except for the local lore
well you've been in this business since
2001 doing special effects makeup and
there's about a couple two Halloweens
ago we have a photo you did Rocky and I
I was Frankenstein and Rocky was the
Bride of Frankenstein I think we have
the photo right there stunning work
right there Rocky look at us stunning
and we are actually in this movie you
are you have a cameo in this movie right
alongside papashango brilliant Papa
Shawn go the WWE Superstar yeah you guys
are are auditioning for roles and uh
oddly enough you don't get the roll oh
oh spoiler alerts were IMD famous now
because of this I'm super excited to be
part of this new movie it's very cool
and it's great to have you in my my
first film yeah first film where did you
love of monsters and horror come from
well it all started when I was a kid I
absolutely loved like He-Man and the
Ninja Turtles and characters and
creatures but then in high school that
turns to Freddy Krueger and Jason right
so I just took off running with the
horror thing and you're supposed to
decide what you do when you're in high
school and I was like I'm gonna make
horror movies and that was what I did
we're excited about the first one I'm
ready to appear a Comic Con with you
Rocky we're going to Comic-Con we're
going places Tom thank you so much and
the movie is out this weekend Rocky over
to you